une question si vous permettez précise à
monsieur mathieu du gâteau sur monsieur
grâce sur capgemini parce que ça fait
parler dans la presse il ya un ancien
salarié de capgemini qui est recruté en
mars 2020 au service de correspondance
de l'elysée et qui a eu recours à votre
cabinet pour réorganiser
le dit service est ce que vous pourriez
nous présenter rapidement cette
prestation et nous en préciser le
montant et nous indiquer aux siciliens
des règles déontologiques qui ont été
mises en oeuvre comme ça va être le
dernier tour de table je vais rajouter
une troisième question pour tout le
monde pour tout le monde je vais je
voulais vous nous expliquer les
avantages que vous trouvez au mécénat de
compétences en quoi est-ce que c'est
plus bordés qu'une prestation pro bono
c'est que le porno est quand même très
fortement interrogé d'ailleurs certains
d'entre nous ont dit qu'ils se gardait
bien d'y avoir recours donc quelques
précisions sur le mécénat de compétences
ce qu'on comprenne bien ce dont il
s'agit et comment vous vous l'envisagez
et puis on sera obligé malhomme malgré
nos frustrations non rester là mais on
va déjà faire sur ces trois questions
enfin tout cas sur deux questions
communes tout le tour de table monsieur
google merci
alors concernant la circulaire nous ne
commentons pas les propos des ministres
et leur volonté politique donc là je ne
vais pas m'exprimer là dessus et nous
prenons acte de cette décision ça c'est
le premier point concernant
une mission qui est lui en 2020 jouer
d'ici là la réponse et de l'estrie
etienne s'ils voulaient qu'on prolonge
dans le détail
les conditions de
réalisation de cette mission nous avons
été sollicités de mémoire sous l'accord
cadre ugap
pour réaliser une mission auprès des
services de l'élysée qui était la
première mission cause auprès des
services de l'elysée depuis
de mémoire on n'en faisait pas ce qu'on
a réalisé en 2020 on a répondu à une
seule citation on la finit à une analyse
qualité de ce qu'on avait fait on me
livre avons été validée est on est on a
fini la mission
question c'est est pas celle ci mais ce
n'est pas gênant de votre point de vue
que ce soit un ancien salarié de
capgemini qui soit chargée de de
revisiter le service des correspondances
de l'elysée et qui est donc un ancien
salarié de capgemini qui a dans sa
nouvelle fonction au sein de l'elysée
recours à votre cabinet pour réorganiser
le dit service je vous invite à poser
des questions à des lisible que pour le
coup c'est pas de notre responsabilité
du tout mais bella est pas d'avis nous
rêvons à des sollicitations qui sont
couverts par l'accord cadre là en
l'occurrence de l'ugap nous répondons à
cette sollicitation c'est pas nous avoir
un avis sur qui au sein de
l'organisation cliente
des classes de d'un point de vue
déontologique penser qu'il n'y a pas de
citoyen mon client paierait donc d'un
point de vue déontologique mon ami je
voulais bien tout à l'heure d'un point
de vue éthique on a été qualifiée comme
entreprises des plus éthiques au monde
depuis novembre consécutivement ça
traduit quoi ça traduit une organisation
spécifique un investissement important
une orientation spécifique des processus
des plans de formation soit 12 ans
personnellement je connaissais
réponse c'est que ça concerne le donneur
d'euros
2 j'ai deux choses d'abord faire la
clarté sur cette mission et en toute
transparence c'est par une belle mission
ce serait intéressant que vous nous
expliquer ce qu'est ce qu'elle a permis
de réaliser mais aussi vous revenir sur
ces questions de déontologie parce que
votre question en fait toucher du doigt
je pense une partie votre avis sur cette
mission donc effectivement on a été
sollicité comme mathieu dougados l'être
dans le cadre de missions ugap donc on a
été sollicité par le gars par le service
du courrier de l'elysée donc devant
c'est vrai qu'on est en mesure de vous
dire qui est le client dans le service
courrier de l'elysée et c'est pas de
notre responsabilité c'est analyser de
le préciser dans le cadre de deux
missions qui ont été dans le cadre du
conseil en systèmes d'information
puisque notre sujet était d'élaborer les
infrastructures technologiques pour
utiliser des outils d'automatisation de
la lecture du courrier l'elysée ce qui
permettait de produire des rapports
beaucoup plus complet du courrier qui
était reçu par le président de la
république et donc tu permets d'avoir
l'accès à l'ensemble du courrier qui
reçoit c'est vrai qu'il ya un point
derrière votre va être votre remarque
qui est que
là il s'agit en l'occurrence le salarié
puisqu'on a été sollicité par la presse
donc s'il s'agit d'un salarié qui est
pas issu du conseil est menacée fortin
l'hermétisme entre des activités de
conseil et celles qui sont réalisés mais
le point qui est derrière votre question
c'est qu'il est fréquent que l'état
recrute nos salariés et je crois que la
mise ou là dit elle elle souhaite plutôt
le faire mais ça nous met toujours dans
cette situation 7 me contre actuellement
quand on a une prestation de service
auprès de l'état en principe ne salarie
n'ont pas vocation à être recrutés c'est
assez particulier dérogatoire et
vis-à-vis de l'état on n'applique pas
ces clauses contractuelles parce qu'on
trouve que l'état se renforce en
recrutant nos salariés ça nous arrive
encore la semaine dernière si vous et
par ailleurs c'est
généralement dans une situation dans
lequel qu parce que dans le cadre d'une
mission est à considérer que ce qu'on
faisait était de nature pérenne et qu'il
a souhaité pérenniser nos mii quand ça
se passe ça nous met dans une situation
complexe et c'est pour ça je voudrais
vous faire toucher du doigt ce point
parce que
en termes de déontologie
chez notre client en cours de mission va
se retrouver à nos anciens salariés donc
la règle qu'on applique et je pense dans
vos travaux ce serait intéressant de
clarifier les choses la règle qu'on
applique nou sé on accepte de lever les
clauses contractuelles qui permettent un
sari de rejoindre nos clients à la
condition qu'il y ait un cadre de
déontologie qui soit fixe et donc on a
la question s'est posée encore très
récemment pour que ce salarié ne soit
pas en contact avec l'entreprise
capgemini j'espère que ma réponse est
claire
alors n'hésitez pas à me demander de la
préciser
[Musique]